There are answers to our questions.
the simplest things that pass through our consciousness to
the big questions about life and faith.
The word apologetics comes from the Greek word apologia, which can be translated as
answer. It means to give a reason, a defense, or an answer for what we believe
and why we believe it. When I was in college, I went to a friend's wedding and had
to fly home alone. I got to the airport in the morning and learned that my flight
was delayed about three or four hours so I turned around to go wait and I
saw another young man about my age he was in college and I thought you know what
here's an opportunity to go talk with him and maybe share my faith but then my
next thought was you know what I am really tired God if you want me to share with
him he's gonna have to sit by me on the plane I finally boarded the plane and I I
sat down in seat 9A. A few moments later, I saw this young man walking down the
aisle and of course I'm wondering where he's gonna sit and he sits right next to me
me on the plane. I finally boarded the plane and I sat. A
so I introduced myself, struck up a conversation and eventually the topic turned
towards spiritual things. He asked me what I believe.
I said, I'm a Christian, I believe in Jesus.
He said, if you're a Christian, Does that mean you think that the Bible is true and
it's the Word of God? I said, yes.
He looked at me point blank. I'll never forget it.
He said, how do you really know the Bible's true?
And although my parents had trained me to give an answer, for some reason in this
circumstance, I fumbled around. And to be honest with you, I gave an answer that was
really weak.
I walked away from that encounter a little bit upset and frustrated that I didn't
have a better response. And I remember thinking, next time, I'm going to have a
better answer. In fact, I remember having a resolve that said, if God gives me the
chance to be in significant spiritual conversations again, I'm going to have a good
reason for why I believe in Christianity and specifically why I think the Bible is
true.
In 1 Peter 3.15, the Apostle Peter says to put Christ first in our
life, but then to be ready with an answer for the hope within in and to give it with
gentleness and to give it with respect towards other people.
What's fascinating to me about this passage is the pattern in which Peter says to
In 1 Peter 3:15, the Apostle Peter says to put Christ first in our
Sometimes we flip this around. Sometimes we want to be ready with an answer before
we've really submitted our lives to Christ.
And when When that happens, oftentimes the results can be harmful.
But when we first find our identity in Christ and we experience his forgiveness and
then we do apologetics out of a spirit of love, it can make a powerful difference in
somebody's life.
Being an apologist is not a spiritual gift like wisdom, discernment or teaching.
Being an apologist is not just for pastors, teachers, parents and professors.
confessors, we are all called to be ready with an answer for the hope within.
I think C.S. Lewis is right. The question is not if we will be apologists, but how
good of an apologist will each of us be?
Apologetics has been a staple of the Christian faith since its inception.
Jesus was a kind of apologist and the first followers of Jesus that came after the
apostles, many of them were called apologists because they gave positive evidences
for the Christian faith and responded to objections against it.
How much have you thought about why you believe as you believe?
Are you ready with an answer when someone asks you why you think the Bible is true?
Have you thought through why if God is all good and all powerful, he allows evil?
And have you thought through a response when people say that science conflicts with
faith? and just as importantly are you ready to share that answer with others when
they ask you the reason for the hope within we are called as Christians to be
ready to make a case for the Christian faith we're called to put forth arguments for
what we believe now don't confuse that with being argumentative that's a very
different thing we are not called to be divisive in how we treat people but each of
us are called to be ready with an answer from the hope within and that's exactly
what we're going to do in this Bible study.
I'm going to help you develop your convictions that Christianity is true and also
have the confidence to share that faith with others.
And just remember this, we are called to boldly speak truth, but we are to always do
it in love.